And, finally, on Sunday night,
the Buffalo Bills face off
against the Kansas City --
[ Boisterous cheering
and applause ]
Yeah, why not?
Little Buffalo, New York.
Yeah, little Buffalo fans, sure.
-Yeah.
[ Cheering and applause ]
Yeah.
We're in New York.
[ Applause ]
The Buffalo Bills face off
against the Kansas City Chiefs.
-Whoo!
[ Laughter and applause ]
Someone pretended. "Pretend
we're from Kansas City."
[ Laughter ]
Now, you know,
at the end of every season,
they give out awards,
like Most Valuable Player,
but they also give out awards
during the season.
I'll show you what I mean.
It's time
for "Tonight Show Superlatives."
[ Cheering and applause ]
-♪ "Tonight Show" ♪
♪ "Superlatives" ♪
♪♪
-Our first player is
from the Bills...
[ Cheering and applause ]
He was voted...
[ Laughter, cheering,
and applause ]
"Guys!
Real funny."
Up next from the Chiefs is...
He was voted...
[ Laughter, cheering,
and applause ]
"It's pretty simple, you know,
you just type in all your..."
Next up from the Chiefs is...
[ Laughter ]
He was voted...
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Wow!
-[ Voice breaking ]
"I'm almost ready for harvest."
[ Laughter ]
Next up from the Bills is...
He was voted...
[ Laughter and applause ]
"Alright, let's split up.
I'll meet you at the party.
-Zmm!
-Hookhand's not real."
[ Laughter ]
Up next from the Bills is...
He was voted...
[ Laughter, cheering,
and applause ]
Next from the Chiefs is...
He was voted...
[ Laughter and applause ]
[ As Wayne Campbell ]
It's a simple ch'yeah
or no way question.
[ Laughter ]
Next from the Chiefs is...
He was voted...
[ Laughter and applause ]
Next up from the Bills is...
He was voted...
[ Laughter and applause ]
"Does that guy work here?"
Next up from the Bills is...
[ Cheering and applause ]
He was voted...
-Aw.
[ Laughter and applause ]
And, finally,
from the Chiefs is...
He was voted...
There you have it. Those are
your "Superlatives"!